you know taking a three week break from
YouTube coming by plane this is my first
game I think it's that I feels good
feels good to be back now I was really
missing out hey Jack what why don't you
lay still there and let me tickle in and
your little Irish pooper
hey don't close your butts oh you close
your butt when I come near you yes stop
stop going in morning you need to plug
it oh you're right where I need you this
game goes too fast am I supposed to [ __ ]
or am I not supposed to [ __ ] I don't are
you supposed to [ __ ] jack I don't get it
yeah you're supposed to getting the
portholes of everyone else
oh [ __ ] come on come on I can still get
what hey we went full circle look at
this cross my legs hole you me need to
go [ __ ] yourself I think it's a point
for that well you can just [ __ ] yourself
then what's your point man police
officer I unlocked police officer I
assume that's a milk man milk hey I got
a fool I got a hula hoop now where do
you choose your outfits it just came to
me
okay there's an opportunity up listen
you clicked on it oh it's granny oh
hello oh boy come on come on
Oh sound do you know what really bothers
me about this game it's like what we're
all the vaginas huh you sure bothers me
about this game all the penises are
uncircumcised or are Circle Jess yeah
how about what about that one I have
ways to foreskin where's the
uncircumcised penis son huh where's my
penis equality uh-huh
wait is that dude just stuck her my app
I just learned that jack has an
uncircumcised penis that's good I didn't
know that that's good to know now now I
have Jack's penis in my brain that's
great thank you for that thank you for
that everyone all right well I'm getting
forced into this hole here that ain't
consent I want that to be known all
right well lemon pink penis get in the
hole this is the kind of video where we
can just upload without the gameplay and
it will just it'll be just this
interesting what are you doing don't do
that do I think that red one is in there
playing so we're gonna have to shove it
in we have to shove the red party
oh come on get in
oh come on red penis get it I get it now
hold man it's too hard
we are 12 clearly come on okay I get it
I get I push you and you push him yeah
this is a different type of docking
giggle giggle giggle huh you got it
oh you got it you got it come on man
yeah no yeah all right let's play I had
almost as fun in the menu Oh
oh [ __ ] oh he's going crazy oh my god
happening what the hell was that
come on no the game that should never
have been made you know this this game
really shows that videogames is in fact
art yeah
damn it [ __ ] me I'm sorry I had to yell
like come on come on green hey come on
stop in there there you go green circle
Hey boobers full circle there you go
okay so you get one point for
penetration and you get one point for
[ __ ] but it's just like real life
[ __ ] when you're walking down the street
oh yeah happens all day no Jack and its
head I want key is to figure out where
you are then key is to figure out who's
gonna [ __ ] you and who you want to [ __ ]
yeah I like how you always go for me as
well I do because next fear you know
what means a lot Matt I think it's just
a natural attraction happening there
well that was guess I'll just [ __ ]
myself
get away Green Venus hey Jack hey Jack
I'm shy I didn't know that all I could
do to avoid a penis into my ass was a
clench you know your your exercises
make sure you clench every day kids
sorry no day keeps the dick come on come
on come on give me your [ __ ] Jack
give me your [ __ ] you can control it
give me your ass yeah
got them ah-ha [ __ ] me [ __ ] me yes no no
no no get in there what the [ __ ]
I need this jack I need this victory I
need this is really important Jimmy get
in get in get in get in get it
goddamn it get it get it why does it no
mommy
come on behold there you go thanks for
letting me win in the penis game Jack I
really appreciate it did I did I do that
oh my god I'm gonna take my mom I want
to thank no nevermind I don't I don't
want to thank anyone there's nothing to
be said about this game that has already
said through its amazing artwork and
graphics I hope this game wins an Oscar
for its great performance and I want to
thank you jack for letting me letting me
finish there I appreciate that no
problem a good friend always lets his
friend finish you heard it here first
[Music]